wake up guy get in here don't wake up
in other words referencing when gary
fell asleep look how we celebrate the
guy's birthday
there's nothing you can praise this man
about nothing i mean we want to
you're being roasted oh hi gary all
right happy birthday this is your prep
this is your birthday happy birthday
sewer face
your gift is you still have a job
[Laughter]
you shouldn't be clearing your throat
you should be clearing your desk
you call yourself a producer the last
thing you produced was four gallons of
phlegm you
[ __ ] do something for this show already
even high pitch eric calls you a lazy
piece of [ __ ]
freddie's doing very well he's doing
great yes all right good you know i was
gonna discuss that joke with gary howard
but he was busy
sleeping people say you look like john
oates
yeah if john oates took a [ __ ] and stuck
teeth in it
your mouth is atrocious gary's the only
person whose breath smells better
after eating [ __ ]
come on gary and your book is a piece of
garbage
that book your book is like a porno no
one ever
gets to the end
and you're delusional about your
storytelling gary
i'm telling you that it's horrible stop
it stop
the moment gary fell asleep in the
office we all loved it it was the only
time you could finally shut the [ __ ] up
holy [ __ ] your stories gary they need an
intermission
it's ridiculous your wife sits on your
face
not for sex but they shut you the [ __ ]
you can't wrap up a [ __ ] thing mix up
your lips around john heinz [ __ ]
here's an idea for wrap-up wrap yourself
up in a garbage bag and jump in the
[ __ ] hudson
i'm sal governelli thank you guys thank
you hey come on gary
it's very good oh wow sal you were on
fire well
gary makes it easy all you have to do is
mention his hair plugs you'll be even
yeah it's true i'm going to roast him on
his birthday
was it hard for you to sit there while
uh sal rose did you
no not at all at the end of the day i
know i'm a better person than he is
rolls right off your back yeah that's
why gary is a good sport right yeah
well he's stupid too so he doesn't
realize it